les jo
les critiques bien entendu s'intéresse
au fond de vos livres mais selon vous
s'intéresse-t-il assez à la forme
à lecteurs c'est à dire les critiques en
france aux états unis monde entier vous
étiez j'ai intérêt à
cause de mes déclarations politiques je
les fais non pas par goût mais parce
qu'on attend suez de monde en russie
qu'il ne reste presque plus personne
pour dire les choses comme elles se sont
passées
il n'y as pas respectés comme au
début
à cause de ses déclarations publiques
presque tous les critiques me prennent
pour un homme politique
je n'ai lu que des jugements
sur les prises de positions politiques
je ne connais pratiquement pas
d'articles critiques sur mon heure
mais ce qui est vrai c'est que votre
célébrité comme rescapées et
dénonciateur du goulag comme ennemi juré
du communisme fait parfois oublier que
vous êtes avant tout et d'abord un
écrivain
damier de chiens vaches et j'en ai
beaucoup d'admiration plus j'avance en
âge et pas plus je suis triste d'être
célèbre non pas pour mon activité
principale mais pour mon activité
secondaire
l'imam a consacré un livre voilà ça
c'est un livre de critique littéraire
en france plus qu'ailleurs on prête
attention à cet aspect là de mon heure
mais aux etats-unis non on ne considère
uniquement comme un homme politique